tech companies have been easing us into
gadgets and services that make use of
virtual eyes and ears for a while now
things that might have made us
uncomfortable even a few years ago are
part of everyday life
Alexa listens for a request to turn on
the lights and the music ring and mast
watch us and every stranger that comes
near our door in places like San
Francisco being followed around by
cameras in a cashier Lift store isn't
really creepy anymore it's just what you
do when you're hungry like I am right
now I think about privacy more than the
average person and I still regularly
grab snacks at my local Amazon go store
here in Las Vegas at CES the year's
biggest tech show we got a peek at where
this technology is headed in the not so
distant future companies are showcasing
tech that combines cameras sensors and
artificial intelligence in ways they say
will make our lives easier and safer in
exchange for evermore monitoring often
you won't even know the technology is
there like in the case of the hotel I'm
in right now it's hiding out in these
planters which raises some interesting
questions about you know consent meet
pat scan a technology that uses
microwave radar chemical sensing and
object detection to spot guns knives and
even drugs in a bag or on a person say
in the parking lot of a school it's AI
cameras can be paired with a smart
locking system that can automatically
secure a building if there's a weapon
detected outside and it could all happen
covertly while you're going to see a
show or picking your kids up from school
or rooting for your favorite baseball
team this system has already set to be
installed at the home field of the
Cincinnati Reds Pat scan doesn't have
facial recognition built in but it can
be added if a client specifically asks
for it clients can also decide whether
or not to let people know they're being
scanned the company says it doesn't
collect or store data associated with
specific individuals another similar
technology platform is iris which
combines various sensors to figure out
what's going on in a car cameras can
detect objects eye movements and even
some emotional facial expressions radar
can confirm the presence of a person
plus track your heart rate and
respiration thermal sensors pick up body
in surface temperatures how might this
be useful well for one thing object
detection may mean one day getting an
alert from your driverless cab that
about to leave your bag behind for
drivers body analytics can be used for
the perfect steering wheel adjustment
size appropriate air bags can be
deployed
if a child is screaming in the back seat
calming music might be cued up
are you eating or texting or not keeping
your eyes on the road enough
what's your threshold for road rage the
system is designed to figure out if
you're stressed it can also take cues
from your facial expressions and body
language to guess when your mind is
wandering the same data collection that
enables autopilot features that could be
a godsend one day could turn into a
nightmare the next how much do we want
our cars to really know about us because
that information land in the hands of
insurance companies or an attorney
arguing a lawsuit against us over an
accident the answer to all of this is
absolutely yes the company says the
benefits far outweigh any privacy
concerns it fully expects this data to
be used to help shed light on what
happened before an accident and for
drivers to share it with their insurance
companies the earliest iris will be on
the road is in Karma's rivero in 2021
these are fresh capabilities that could
very well be life-changing
even life-saving one day we may welcome
all these benefits but in the meantime
we'll continue to think about the
trade-offs
[Music]